i am so excited about a new movie you
guys have probably heard about this
movie the supporters it's starring the
good liars this movie is [ __ ]
hilarious and i think it might have been
a mistake but for some reason i got an
advanced screening of this movie it's
about two doofuses that get wrapped up
in the maca trump bumping gulp [ __ ]
boneheads the characters names are
derrick and dale and they have a podcast
called the derrick and dale show that
they do out of the back of a minivan
that they live out of they're pissing
and jugs
they're chasing their dreams of having
this hit cable show on fox news and when
that all gets crushed they decide to do
their own research and travel all across
the country during the 2020 presidential
campaign armed with only their white
male fragility and a camera
they run into the likes of andrew yang
tom steyer elizabeth warren president
joe biden marjorie hoof foot green don
booger sugar junior they even have a
close encounter in the film with the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopypants
himself donald trump is in the film you
cannot miss this one it is a
fantastically funny movie starring the
good liars you know these comedians from
their viral videos out to occupy wall
street manga rallies and even the
january 6 insurrection that footage from
the january 6 insurrection is in the
film do not miss this movie it is
released on november 4th go to
thesupportersmovie.com in reserve so you
see the movie first you have to see this
[ __ ] movie the good liars present in
association with midas pictures
executive producers michael rappaport
the supporters don't
[ __ ] miss it